joining me now is Congressman Mark
Greene chairman of the homeland security
committee and member of the House
Foreign Affairs committee Congressman do
you believe the administration when they
say that the Chinese didn't glean any
intel usable Intel from that balloon
absolutely not Laura if they can control
its elevation and its path which we know
for a fact they did that thing changed
elevation several times they had to be
able to get information back there's
there's no way did you ever think you'd
see a Time
where the United States of America with
the money that we have put into our
National Defense
was just a laughing sock I'm sorry a
laughing stock uh in the world watching
this this thing take place there are a
lot of people on TV today are kind of
downplaying it oh well we'll say this is
this is all this is a big nothing burger
if I heard that phrase one more time I'm
gonna throw up but what does this say to
the Chinese that we were just passive
observers until you know Biden uh
decided this is political Fallout they
had to take it down sure this was an
invasion of United States Sovereign
territory our space by a Chinese spy
balloon the general officers who advised
that that thing not be shot down should
be fired that's step one to Future
competing with China fire whoever
advised him not only in Austin is it not
whoever it isn't it up to you guys to
find out who made that call believe me
same thing it happened in Afghanistan
we're back and we're back a year and a
half later and yet another embarrassment
for the country I know for a fact eight
uh the house Foreign Affairs committee
is planning on the withdrawal they're
going to dig into that and we're going
to to dig into who made that house armed
services will dig into who made this
decision
well we have to stop funding them I mean
unless the only thing they understand is
pi
they keep getting these giant increases
in the defense budget every why are they
going to change well they're not going
to change clearly the efficiencies the
there's a ton of things to change over
there no doubt about it but number one
we've got to find out who made these bad
decisions we need Warriors over there
our military is supposed to their job is
to deter war and when it happens kill
people and break things not uh train
people on this woke stuff that is tying
up our time we got ships colliding in
the sea and a three-star Admiral made it
just made a report on it that it was
because there wasn't time to train on
what they really need to train on
instead they're out there worrying about
this woke stuff that's being taught not
only at the academies but throughout the
force well how much time are they
spending on that he said they have to
train uh at West Point on white Rage
that's what he said in that
Congressional testing I'm not sure he
was really read in on what was happening
at the Academy at the time
um to add insult to injury by the way
some are concerned that the technology
that might be leaned from this balloon
might have an interesting origin watch
it does worry me about the Chinese just
how capable they are of collecting
intelligence in this country I mean
there are all sorts of things we don't
know what that balloon was carrying what
kind of cameras whether it had
Communications equipment or even sensors
we used to drop sensors on China to
monitor their nuclear weapons are they
doing the same thing at our Minuteman
basis what scares me is when they get
this stuff out of the oceans could turn
out to be American technology which
there's a good chance it will be
well there's very very much a chance we
have a lot of businesses in this country
and cypheus who who has the purpose of
stopping that technology transfer to
China needs more power needs to do their
job better absolutely it's a possibility
too many businesses putting profit over
National Security and it's got to stop
chances one to ten ten being the most
likely of U.S technology being found in
that balloon what are you going to say
that's a tough question you're putting
me on the spot I'd say five
that's not good no
Congressman thank you great to see you
in studio tonight hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else